bonjour je m'appelle Mathieu chaise je
suis le directeur technique et aussi le
fondateur d'astrolabe SAS astrolabe SAS
et actuellement incubé à Paris Saclay et
au ski cube de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
on est deux cofondateurs et on cherche à
développer la première station spatiale
complètement robotisée faut que vous
imaginiez un bidon voilà un module qui
va faire 4 mètres de diamètre c'est à
peu près 8 mètres de long pour pour 8
tonnes et à l'intérieur des robots qui
vont conduire les expériences des bras
robots des microscopes des échantillons
qui qui vendent d'un poste de travail à
un autre dans la station et surtout à
l'extérieur un système qui va permettre
de ravitailler de manière automatique
avec un bras robot qui va récupérer les
capsules des échantillons et ensuite ces
capsules vont revenir sur Terre
automatiquement pour ramener aux
scientifiques les échantillons qui ont
été créés dans l'espace on va pouvoir
créer des organes complètement
artificiels vascularisés chose qu'on ne
sait pas faire au sol l'expression même
au niveau génétique des cellules et
différents donc là il y a des grands
pour la création de nouveaux médicaments
de nouvelles de nouvelles thérapies les
chercheurs auront en permanence accès à
leurs expériences ils pourront voir en
direct ce qui se passe sous le
microscope ils pourront aussi on espère
à terme manipuler en direct chacune des
expériences on va avoir un premier
prototype au sol fin 2024 on veut faire
voler ensuite en 2025 ce qu'on appelle
le mini lave une mini station en 2027 on
va on pourra commencer à ravitailler et
une première station et je dis une
conversation parce qu'on va en faire
plusieurs en 2029 et à terme va avoir
tous les ans une station qu'on lance et
on cherche à faire une levée globale de
plus d'un million un quasiment un
million et demi avec des investissements
privés auteur d'un demi million les
futurs clients pour nous c'est avant
tout les instituts de recherche et aussi
évidemment sur le marché commercial les
les grandes entreprises biotech et
Pharma pour qu'elle développe les futurs
médicaments qu'on ne peut pas développer
aujourd'hui au sol